hi i want to thank lab roots for
allowing me to share some things with
you today
uh we call this talk to contemporary
healers responsible conversation
uh because there is a certain amount of
responsibility that healthcare providers
have in a space that obviously if we're
talking about
cannabis here is federally illegal
so going through a high quality
education
involves us with certain attestations
the things we have to do that discuss in
a commercial sense
what we're going to talk about and the
standards for that
involve revealing that if i'm going to
discuss some product that is being used
off label i disclose that that's what
that red box there you see is involving
and the fact is because cannabis is a
schedule one substance
all of the things we're talking about
today are
by definition off label so with that
disclaimer
i have no commercial ties and this is
a huge subject it's involving things
that seem
seemingly can be complicated so i hope
in this next hour to be able to share
with you some of those complicated
subjects
in particular ones that look at
the occurrence of something in the
spirit of national doctor's day
now doctor's day is actually a real
holiday
and i believe it was george bush one who
decided that there was going to be one
day
historically that could be used to
represent
the kindness and compassion that
physicians provide in alleviating pain
and suffering
and isn't it interesting that the date
of march 30th was chosen
and that's because that's the date of
the discovery
of ether used as an anesthetic now i'm
an anesthesiologist
and the value of alleviating pain does
not escape me
in that back in the 1840s actually in
1842
a medical student in georgia state
named crawford long through observing
the use of
ether recreationally it was known as
ether frolics in the day and laughing
gas nitrous
oxide these were sideshow carnival
events
but it took that careful observation to
see that if people
took some ether fell down perhaps in a
way that looked like it would hurt
they got up and didn't seem to recall
any pain
so in fact crawford long then used ether
and reported it to remove the cyst from
the back of
someone's neck and as a result of that
operational observation of the
initiative of
seeing its use for pain took something
which was used recreationally
and now has changed medicine forever
pain is the first thing that i think if
we look at
as a quality of life and a compassionate
outreach
it's important to understand that not
all
professionals are trained in treating
pain the same way or perhaps even the
understanding
of what really pain is uh pain can be
physical and that's the way most people
think of it
but pain if it's being regarded as an
intolerable symptom
of disease or an experience has a
different context and in that sense
pain can be regarded as being not only
physical but
psychological or even spiritual if it's
truly intolerable
and that's a good starting point for
which we can talk about the objectives
of this talk
i'd like to be able to speak about
plant-based medicines for a little while
but the real emphasis is not on the
plant's chemistry itself
but on the receptors in all of us
that the cannabis plant in this case
reveal
how it works and their role in
maintaining the essential human
physiologic balances we all depend on
for health
beyond there we'll talk about the
clinical significance of what we call
evidence-based data there's not as much
of it as you would think
partly because of the constraints of
prohibition however
there are a wealth of anecdotal reports
and we'll compare just what the
differences there
are and finally we'll talk about the
legislative progress
that's been made throughout the country
in the last 25 years
since the mid 1990s when california
became the very first state to recognize
medical value to cannabis they're now 33
states we'll talk about more
and the important thing about a medicine
is that it needs to have
responsible legislation that ensures
promoting better patient outcomes
so historically then with plants in
medicine the nobel prize
back in 1947 sir robert robinson
received it for his work with a certain
group of chemicals
that are called alkaloids alkaloids are
what are called water
soluble chemicals most botanical
medicines we think of today
come from alkaloid chemicals the plants
generally
use these chemicals themselves for
protecting themselves
from predators and also for ensuring its
own reproduction
and and propagation so an understanding
of how
certain plant chemicals also can benefit
health
were the contributions that sir robinson
made and that
was awarded the nobel prize way back in
1947
and most of his productive work was done
in the very beginning of the 20th
century
so a slide that i'd like to share with
you beyond that
concerns this chemical structures
actually of
really the life blood in a sense of a
plant which is chlorophyll
compared to hemoglobin in human beings
and the two molecules as seen side by
side here
are virtually the same chemical
structures
with the exception of what's in the
middle here in these pictures
human beings to the picture on the right
rely on
iron such that hemoglobin which is there
to carry oxygen it's essential you
couldn't live without it
all animals have some forms of
hemoglobin and a physician
uses iron to fulfill
hemoglobin's maximum capacity to do what
it's designed to do deliver oxygen
plants on the other hand have their
essential life
blood in chlorophyll now chlorophyll
does a really interesting thing and it
was around long before hemoglobin and
animals because plants were around first
it it gives plants the ability to make
their own food
from light and to do that
in the same place where iron fits in
hemoglobin
plants have magnesium actually related
to iron in that they are both considered
chemically
as two plus cations remarkably similar
biochemistry
plants and human beings share and that's
a powerful slide
the treatment of diseases in
particularly diseases of parasites
received the nobel prize recently
actually it was in 2015 the nobel prize
for medicine
in 2015 went to a plant-based chemical
called
artemisinin and it in fact was
rediscovered from ancient chinese texts
from
thousands of years ago for its value
treating
parasitic diseases including things like
malaria
and um parasitic diseases then
very often waterborne kill thousands if
not millions of
human beings every year around the globe
and in this case
the rediscovery of that botanical
medicine worthy
of a nobel prize was awarded just within
the last several years
it's particularly a timely comment
because if anyone is following the news
concerning a covet
19 and some news released even earlier
today
understanding that this is going to be
released in a few days from now
chloroquine is another example of
an anti-parasitic medicine that's been
used
and has connections back to treating
malaria
through chinchona bark found in the new
world but
basically developed through pharmacy in
victorian england days
as the scourge of malaria was making the
thames river
basically contaminated with malaria in
in what we regard today as being
eradicated in london
the science involving cannabis is its
chemicals itself
you can see from the what we call here
the biosynthesis of what chemicals lead
to the cannabis's best known chemical
components
in the blue square boxes it shows thc
and cbd here those are the two we know
most about but many of those other boxes
include
other what are called cannabinoids each
having their own
independent biologic functions and in
fact the plant has them
in an acid form that if you look at the
lower left of the legend
upon air and light and heat the loss of
this co2 molecule called decarboxylation
actually is what releases cannabis is
best known
psychotropic medicine in this case thc
and most of the concern about thc from a
regulatory perspective
is about that particular singular
molecule thc
this was an important discovery of thc's
chemical structure that didn't come
about until the early 1960s
compared to things like opium which were
known decades before for even chemical
structures
so as we follow then the important
discoveries of plant-based medicines
we can look way back not to the modern
plant that emphasizes thc
but to land race fields that
ethnobotanically cultures had
grown for thousands of years at
different points in the globe
very few of which still exist today but
one such fields can be found in the
becca valley of lebanon
and it's interesting that in that field
the
balanced amount of thc and cbd otherwise
we call it we know it familiarly now is
canada diol
we're approximately in equal amounts and
that's particularly interesting because
even
today a modern drug that has been
introduced in i believe 29 countries
across the world
called sativex or naviximos is the
generic name is a preparation with equal
parts of those two particularly
better known cannabinoids
there's another component though of
cannabis chemicals that has more
recently gained a lot of appreciation
for
how it affects the particular users
impression upon what's the difference
from one varietal of the plant to
another
in terms of its effect and those are a
family of chemicals called
terpenes terpenes are those chemicals
that plants
use generally to their defensive
advantage or
their reproductive advantage that are
what give plants their
smells the most common terpene in nature
is pine pinene it's called and and
these chemicals now we're learning much
more about them
and certain dominant or recessive
genetics in the varietals of cannabis
that are seen today
express different amounts of those
terpenes
terpenes then can be categorized and
used
in a purposeful way because those
particular
groups in that pionee class may have
certain abilities
to reverse some of the memory impairment
that thc brings
some of the other chemicals including
caryophyllene there which is also found
in black pepper
can have some wonderful
anti-inflammatory effects
and and other terpenes then do
contribute
to a given cannabis users interpretation
of those effects
but one plant that changed the world
forever
happens to be a plant that was found and
identified in the early 1970s this is
richard evan schulte's
a very famous harvard ethnobotanist
showing a broadleaf plant discovered in
the kandahar section of afghanistan
back then it's a plant that had wide
leaves
but nevertheless had lots of thc in it
lots of also a particular terpene called
mircine
and as you can see here this is not a
typical cannabis plant because
a typical cannabis plant is towering
over dr schulte's here it would be in
the neighborhood of 1820
22 feet tall in one growing season
as you can see these are four med most
five foot
squatty plants that also became favorite
favorites with people in the cannabis
breeding world in these days and for the
next
several decades because being of that
size
they're easy to hide from a helicopter
and so the illegality of this
lent this particular plant's genetics to
be ones that are found in virtually all
plants
you'll see in the modern plants today
so that modern plant today compared to
back in the 1970s has changed markedly
the amount of delta 9 thc which is as i
said the plant's really primary
intoxicating chemical
its dry weight content back in the 1970s
was probably not much more than say
three or four percent
and today it's not uncommon if you went
into a dispensing point in those states
where it's legal
to see plants that have been tested
upwards of about 25
of thc and that's actually quite a
remarkable
feat of cultivation in that this is
a secondary metabolite and the dry
weight of
one particular molecule cannabis has
the concentration of those molecules
developing
in what are called buds the flower
bracts of the female plant
have the greatest concentration one of
those buds is shown in this picture on
the left
and the cannabinoids and the terpenes we
spoke about a moment ago were
manufactured and stored
in tiny little structures known as
capital glandular trichomes
those little structures you see over the
word trichomes that look like either a
golf ball on a tea or maybe a little
mushroom
that's the chemical storage that the
cannabis plant
does those trichomes if removed and
separated from the rest of the leafy
part of the plant
become the basis of the fats that are in
there
that would otherwise be hashish
so if we're looking critically then at a
traditional plant
as those found in the land race fields i
mentioned before compared to the modern
plant
the traditional plants before the 70s
kind of had a balance with them and that
evidence balance of naturalized balance
of chemicals that were used by human
beings for thousands of years
throughout the world had an equal amount
more or less between thc and cbd
however since 1970s and the early in
discovery of that other plant the
emphasis
especially under prohibition has been on
that which is prohibited
thc the intoxicating chemical
and right now most modern plants hybrids
emphasize those varieties
with much more thc than cbd which is
being rediscovered
which is a good thing however it means
that the dominant traits from that
afghani kush i showed you the picture of
a little while ago
and another varietal called skunk number
one that happens to be the fragrance
that it brings
uh created short hybrids with lots of
thc
more than cbd and in particular high
amounts of
mircine which is a different terpene we
can speak about a little more at length
so since that time then the cannabis
plant has not necessarily evolved but
it's changed markedly
so that over the last 50 years that thc
content of maybe three four no more than
five percent has skyrocketed up to 25
however cbd is also being rediscovered
and some modern plants today are
actually pushing cbd's
single secondary metabolite and certain
plant varietals
up to around 15 the difference being
either one being unbalanced the two have
different effects
unbalanced thc has many notable side
effects while
unbalanced still cbd as of now
doesn't have many discernible side
effects which may represent a
therapeutic benefit
so the comment on the evolution over the
last 50 years
is that we have really unbalanced modern
plants that in a sense have actually
devolved
probably from the way human beings have
traditionally used cannabis as a
medicine
going back with evidence going back
perhaps as far as 5
000 years ago so when it's used the
other issue is that concentration
and the the way that we treat patients
is with using the lowest effective dose
so one of the problems that happens with
the way patients are largely using
cannabis
today is that they're not starting with
the lowest effective dose
because the products are not really that
low dose to begin with so micro dosing
is something that's getting attention
and yet patients who use
chronically are considerably more
challenging
to dose because their bodies are already
used to
higher dosing that changes the amounts
of the body's own receptors that
cannabis works through
however there are certain balance
strains that are appearing now in
certain dispensings
and those in that middle section there
the middle oval
of balance strains represent perhaps
lower concentrations of both cbd and thc
but represent a balance that's probably
more consistent with how human beings
evolve with cannabis
over those thousands of years so let's
get right into
the the endocannabinoid receptors
themselves
because they have a very unique way that
they work
and they're critically important in
maintaining
the essential balances that our
physiology relies on
most physicians even ones working in the
cannabis space have not fully
put themselves to task to understand
some of these subtle
ways that the body's own endogenous we
call it
receptors work and that's going to be a
major emphasis of one of the objectives
now to bring that about
and that important discovery
the discovery of thc um wasn't
until 1960 and the lab that discovered
that belonged to professor rafael
mushulum
uh at hebrew university in israel but
the most important discovery in terms of
understanding endocannabinoid science
happened
in that same lab nearly 30 years later
michelin's lab identified the body's own
chemicals
that thc is mimicking and that's an
important distinction because
when people say oh well the body's
chemicals are are mimicking thc
no it's the other way around you have
a plant-derived chemical that whether
through a fluke of nature or something
that plants
know in a sense could interact with
not only mammals but endocannabinoids
are found in all animals at least
not only vertebrates but also
invertebrates
insects have a different system but all
animals have
endocannabinoids and it's almost that
the word cannabinoid in this sense can
be misleading in that it makes you think
it's somehow doing what cannabis is
doing cannabis
is doing some of the things that the
body's natural system does
and that became a teaching learning
moment so
by far compared to the 1964 discovery
30 years later the discovery of
anandamide
and 2ag the body's two best known and
initial
uh endocannabinoids is far more powerful
and meaningful to medicines for
further advances this way professor
mishulam is still alive and well he's 89
years old
and uh his contributions in this field
cannot
be overstated so
endocannabinoids were revealed
through the cannabis plant but there are
actually
three very well known receptor systems
that we all have
that were identified through plant
chemicals
not just cannabis but other chemical
plants that had been used for
thousands of years indigenous people as
well as pharmaceuticals
including opioids morphine
or the opium poppy is what was used to
originally discover the existence of
what we know
as endorphins discovered in the
mid-1970s
cannabinoids in the mid-1990s
and even the chili pepper capsaicin
is known to have been used by cultures
thousands of years ago
still is used therapeutically for pain
management
and it works through a third system
called endovaniloids
there are things called trip v1
receptors
they work through this mechanism and the
interactions
of how our bodies deal with all three of
these receptor systems
is therapeutic for the perception of
pain
this is particularly important because
this is not new
in the sense that pharmaceutical
companies have been using
these concepts even before the discovery
of how they were working was appreciated
so there are medicines going back to the
turn of the last century and certainly
through the 1930s
which exploited the use of these three
chemicals
for use as an elixir it doesn't mean it
couldn't have been
abused because they were but certain
chemicals that
all the major pharmaceutical companies
had in their formulary
decades ago took advantage of these
receptor systems
functions in the perception of pain long
before
precisely how they worked was ever
appreciated
if there was ever one report that got my
attention
to the power of what endocannabinoids
can cover as far as treating diseases it
was a paper that was produced
through the nih that summarized the
importance of how this system in human
health
modulates disease that means keeps us in
balance
and this paper from the nih was put
together by two
highly respected md phd researchers
paul packer and george cunos and i've
highlighted in the bottom of the paper
something will enlarge here a moment
the most remarkable statement they said
that modulating
or working with the endocannabinoid
system activity
may have therapeutic potential in almost
all diseases
affecting humans i'll say that again
almost all diseases affecting humans
this is saying how essential it is as a
parallel system say to our immune system
and we'll go over more
exactly on how this works in a little
while but
this explains how people say that
cannabis can be used for something
such as parkinson's disease a brain
disease
and yet still cannabis could conceivably
be effective for say crohn's disease
while people who don't understand how
the mechanism of this
system works could ever have something
that's a brain related disease
effect with a gut related disease as i
just described
this is why and how it happens the fact
is
that all other receptor systems are
subordinate to the effects of the
endocannabinoid system and i'll show you
what some of those receptor systems are
in a little while
the subtitle of that paper was actually
targeting the endocannabinoid system and
i want to point out the importance of
that there because
unless you understand as a biological
basis
how and why this system does what it
does
it could be very challenging to
interpret the limited evidence-based
data that still exists at this moment in
time
with respect to cannabis when used as a
medicine
so a purely focused researcher and i've
drawn the analogy of an archer here
if the archer is able to maintain pure
focus on the target as you see there
they're likely to shoot right where
they're wanting to research however
if their gaze is distracted as i've
pointed a cannabis leaf on the tip of
the arrow
and they're focusing on the arrow tip
and not the target
far more likely to shoot misses so
focused research
is that focused research where the focus
is not so much on the plant especially
for future value
but on the endogenous endocannabinoid
system itself
and this is how it works this is a very
beautiful slide by a company named vitex
and what it shows
is the receptors uh as cb1 listed in the
center of this slide
but it's positioned in what we call a
synapse
the part of the nerve that brings a
signal down from what would otherwise be
the top of this screen
gets transmitted through one nerve and
then gets picked up
by another nerve which is the bottom
portion of the screen's
surface so there's a space called the
synapse that exists between these nerves
and nerve signals get transmitted from
in this case the top to the bottom by
sending different
in this case neurotransmitters from the
first part of that nerve to get picked
up
on the second side on the bottom and
then that nerve in turn
transmits the signal further well it
doesn't matter what the
trans-neurotransmitter is
acetylcholine dopamine melatonin
we have a lot of different medicines
that are regarded as neurotransmitters
and
systems we understand that way but all
of them are affected
by the action of the cannabinoid
receptors cd1 pictured here
on them so here's what's unique about
this system
to begin with nerves are
fat they're lipids and so
unlike the alkaloid medicines that i
showed you in an earlier slide were
identified for their importance
to health care and awarded that way in
the 1940s
by a nobel prize cannabinoids
are different and cannabis is different
because they are not
what are called water soluble alkaloids
these are fats or lipids
and so the environment around a synapse
in a nerve
is in fact a lipid environment and so
what's happening now is that the body's
own cannabinoids the ones that i said
thc is mimicking
can be seen on the bottom surface here
and they're going to be seen i'll bring
up a little circle around them
the two endogenous cannabinoids called
anandamide and 2ag
can be seen where they're actually made
on the post
synaptic neurons surface and they
respond to whatever neurotransmitters
are
going down and affecting that post
synaptic neuron
and then they are made on site and on
demand right where they are
and they go backwards retrograde to the
presynaptic side
to then affect whatever is being
released and that's a
constant fine-tuning balance that not
only each nerve but
every physiologic system is affected by
that's now understood to operate through
this mechanism
in medical school we're generally taught
that nerve impulses
whether from the brain through the
spinal cord back and forth
are sort of regarded like one-way
streets well they're really not one way
at all
because at every single junction here
every single synapse
there's actually a little feedback loop
that keeps us
in constant balance and that's a key
difference compared to thc which you can
see in the green color there
is coming in and affecting cb receptors
but not in a way that maintains
necessarily a balance
thc's impact is not produced on site and
on demand
when taken in its effects tend to be
more global within
all parts of the body and mind and its
effects
instead of being rather instantaneous
and degraded very quickly
by the body's own enzymes its effects
can last for several hours
so in many respects thc is mimicking
only some of the effects of the body's
own endocannabinoids
and not in necessarily a natural way at
all
because we're talking about how it
compares to two natural
ligands so be very careful when someone
someone implies that
oh well cannabis is a natural substance
therefore it's good for you
not all natural substances are
necessarily good
but it certainly does work through a
natural pathway
and it affects everything these as of
2013
represent the other known receptor
systems that influence
all physiologic systems i've identified
up in the top left
corner there the two cb receptors
labeled cb1 and cb2
uh and mentioning those two natural
ligands the things that interface with
those receptors naturally
affecting everything that is known for
our physiology
so that's why when you see someone talk
about
the brain's effects versus what it does
elsewhere in the body
you'll see what we're calling here
central versus peripheral effects
and how wide their effects can be seen
from what
naturally is happening through
endocannabinoids
so let's get into the second of our
objectives talking about the clinical
significance
of what we call evidence-based data as
compared to anecdotal reports
we know an awful lot about anecdotal
reports
but what happens when we're confronted
with the volume
and wealth of them and they're not
scrutinized perhaps as carefully through
the scientific method
what happens is that anecdotal reports
can contribute
to hyperbole and hyperbole on
what cannabis and cannabis chemicals can
do
is running rampant and i i caution
healers or patients when they're looking
at some of these reports
to measure that against the slowly
evolving but
ever-present evidence-based data that
actually does exist today
so the best reference for
a current evidence-based data platform
that i encourage you to look at
would be a commissioned federal report
that was released in early 2017
by the national academies of sciences
engineering and medicine
looking specifically at the health
effects of cannabis and cannabinoids
this was not the first commissioned
federal report
the first report that would have covered
this also extensively was released back
in 1999
barely half a decade from the earth
discovery
of the endocannabinoid system itself and
even that earlier report
commented on its potential effects but
by the time this report came out in 2017
it was very helpful because it now
distinguished
between evidence-based data and those
anecdotal reports
and what i've done in this slide i've
made a few comments from fairly well
respected
references talking about what is known
and accepted
today or should be about the importance
of how
cannabis can help human beings the first
being a quote from the
national institute of health and and
that was saying
up there on the top that modulating the
endocannabinoid system activity
as i showed you on that report paper
earlier
may have therapeutic potential in almost
all diseases affecting humans
nevertheless at this moment in time in
2020
the new england journal made a statement
back in 2013 that largely still applies
in terms of that cannabis is not a
first-line treatment for debilitating
diseases
and the reason i reference that is
because cannabis if it's regarded as an
alternative
medicine kind of implies that
it's rejecting the advances that western
medicine has made in both
both its diagnostic and therapeutic
advances
well western medicine and eastern
medicine
meet in terms of a concept or not even a
concept but
the practice of what we consider as
integrative medicine
where the eastern healers understanding
in particular of plant-based medicines
is absolutely important but when it's
combined with western medicine
scientific method and due process to
determine evidence-based data
then you really have the best of what
both cultural and
the advances of healthcare have realized
and so
the advances in terms of the
evidence-based data as it exists and we
know today
is summarized in the statements i've
listed here for thc
cbd as well as the other cannabinoids
in terms of what it seems that it has
the best efficacy for
particularly there is conclusive
evidence that it works for the
chemotherapy related nausea and vomiting
and culturally what we found is that for
other entities
wasting diseases things like that
nausea and vomiting is something that is
well known to improve
with cannabinoids thc in particular and
why is that important
well we're going to sort of give a
little segue here to talking about
legislation
but the reality of legislative measures
are they've been made much more
effective through a politically
successful
mantra of compassion physicians are
compassionate of course we are
we don't go to school to learn how to
take care of patients and render
safe and effective health care if we
weren't compassionate
but the scientific method by definition
is dispassionate it doesn't consider
those emotions
certainly not being compassionate is not
consistent with
a human humane way of approaching
disease and treatment
but in that sense i want to give you
some historical basis
for some of the earliest understanding
for how cannabis
can be helpful for nausea and vomiting
because it was actually recognized that
way
going back 30 40 years ago when early
patients who developed
aids and hiv-related symptoms
had to tolerate certain medicines which
were
very very hard on stomachs and the
nausea and vomiting of those wasting
disorders
were treated with cannabis into forms of
actually brownies back then
and and there seemed to be efficacy from
it
that has been evidenced then as well as
continued today
that is the evidence of a compassionate
care
mantra that was really not in those days
advanced as as successfully politically
because our understanding of hiv and
aids and who was afflicted back then
didn't really have the compassionate
understanding of who was getting disease
from what
however jump forward 30 years
and now we have children with epilepsy
and the compassionate use of the
different cannabinoid in this case
cannabidiol is what's referenced there
in that second column there where its
efficacy has evidence-based data to show
that there is conclusive proof that it
works particularly for intractable
epilepsy why do i mention that
because an epileptic should not
completely stop
using the medicines that may be working
or currently advised with their
neurologist or epileptologist taking
care of them
but perhaps for certain patients having
intractable epilepsy
as occurs with children with diseases
such as dravet syndrome
or lennis gestalt syndrome two very very
challenging forms of epilepsy to treat
seemingly has evidence-based data
developing now
for the benefits of cannabidiol
cannabidiol by the way also can be
helpful for other things
anxiety and inflammation as far as its
effects
in even treating or in certain
situations making worse
certain diseases involving psychosis and
schizophrenia
are still things where our psychiatric
colleagues
are dealing with understanding cbd
better but it does apparently have
some efficacy without bringing the side
effects of thc with it
thc however going right back to that
other thc comment
is shown to have not necessarily
conclusive
supporting evidence but substantial
evidence as it's been categorized in
that 2017 report
for its efficacy and help for chronic
pain
we do right now a fairly poor job in
treating chronic pain as evidenced
from the side effects both
gastrointestinal and central of opioids
and today's concerns with accidental
opioid overdose deaths
bring that to light and i'll share with
you then
beyond the epileptic child there's a
third
compassionate care mantra evolving
in the use of cannabis for veterans
and veterans who may not have choices
that
are different than opioids or other
drugs that have
certainly significant side effects
cannabis now for the use in veterans
is being discovered and some of that
dates back to the days of vietnam
where cannabis was discovered by certain
gis in vietnam
again this is not that distant history
but ones which
now allow us to rediscover it in the
context of understanding
the mechanism for how these worked which
are not known which were not known back
then
and then finally we bring up what
cannabinoids might be helpful for the
future
looks kind of exciting with respect to
the types of pain from lower urinary
tract
issues perhaps hepatitis c
cancer pain and fibromyalgia
however in contrast even though it can
lower eye pressure as seen in glaucoma
the medicines that are available today
to treat glaucoma
would have cannabis used because of its
side effects and how long or short in
this case
its duration is that the eye drops
available
to treat multiple forms of glaucoma seem
to be
a much better choice than cannabis for
that particular disease
that maybe unfortunately in states which
have advanced certain qualifying
conditions
include glaucoma in that context perhaps
the same thing with als
and perhaps even parkinson's disease but
everything else
at this moment is what we said before is
anecdotal
these are reports that are available for
their interpretation and the supporting
evidence-based data
at this time
this slide discusses the available
formularies that are here
in 2020 and i'd like you just quickly to
look at this slide
relative to the last column on the right
the drug enforcement administration or
dea of the united states has scheduling
of different drugs
either that are prohibited which is the
definition really of schedule one we can
go into detail if someone's interested
but more importantly schedule five at
the bottom right hand corner
is a new designation for canada diol
a company out of england has cannabidiol
in an oil extract form produced as a
product called epidialex that has
recently received fda approval
for treatment of that intractable
epilepsy we talked about a little while
ago
this is important in that it becomes the
very first
plant-based cannabinoid approved through
our food and drug administration
which is the higher standard that we
provide for introducing new medicines
i'd like now to shift to a model that i
use
when i'm teaching about how
and why endocannabinoids are so
important and what they do
so perhaps the hardest thing for those
listening
as i present these next few slides i
believe there's about eight slides
will be to try to think about what i'm
speaking about
but not necessarily in context with what
you may be familiar about
with cannabis use and yet some of the
things i'll say
will be obvious and i'll refer to it in
that context
the reason i'm going back to 1998 for
this particular
article is because not professor
micholem but i believe the most
frequently cited researcher in the world
is an italian researcher named vincenzo
de marzo
and back in 1998 barely three to five
years
after these receptors and the body's
own chemicals again that thc is
mimicking
he said that some of the functions that
body's own cannabinoids are doing are
things that relate
to relaxing
eating sleeping forgetting and
protecting
these are those messages and so i'd like
to present a clinical model
not necessarily approaching these in the
order that i brought up here
but in terms of how we grow so from
conception
right through death cb or cannabinoid
receptors
are essential to our well-being because
as i said before
they have effect in that their function
modulates
or subtly adjusts all the other
physiology that's going on
in us in an effort to sustain life
so what do i mean when i say that let's
look at conception then
and realize that if we look at those
five things that when we're living
and when we're growing in particular we
start with conception
and then the importance of eating and
sleeping for normal
growth as we're developing and growing
is pretty obvious
but as we accrue life's experiences and
the different stressors that
nature disease and everything else
brings us
we have to have the abilities to relax
and in a sense forget some of those
trials and tribulations in order to
go on then finally i've left the bottom
blank for now
but near cd2 receptors which are
different
cb2 receptors are different in that
they're not only involved with the
nervous system
but they're involved with ways that help
protect us
because cb2 receptors even though we
know much
less about them than cb1 receptors they
are there to respond
when and where a disease hits
and right now i assure you that people
who have
healthy endocannabinoid systems
may be in a position to better deal with
a new disease that human beings have not
had to deal with
covid the novel coronavirus that you
hear so much about today
it doesn't mean that cannabis is helpful
for you it means that your general
health
through having a healthy endocannabinoid
systems response to that disease
is what's there that's designed along
with
your immune system to help fight the
effects of disease
where the immune system just about by
definition
is there to approach certain bacterial
and viral
protein invaders the cb2
endocannabinoid receptor system is there
to respond
to the event and evolution of a disease
to keep that disease from essentially
killing you quickly if you want to think
about it in this context then
cb2 receptors and this system
is the system that allows a disease to
become
chronic to understand the mechanism
of how a disease becomes chronic or the
mechanism
of chronicity is the starting blocks for
incredible research that's going to
happen perhaps more than a generation's
worth of research
will be focused on cb2 probably more
than cb1 in the distance
because without the fine balance of
keeping us in balance which is why the
cb2 receptor
is put on a little triangle that
maintains that delicate balance
death ensues and without a healthy
immune system
or endocannabinoid system life is
virtually impossible
so let's look at these individual relax
eat sleep forget and protect things from
the order in which they should be
obviously important
in terms of eating and sleeping
obviously conception
a young mother a child they
have to be able to eat and sleep simply
to start
life and so the essential nature
of cb1 receptors in this context
for growth and reproduction should be
obvious
if we advance them beyond the growth
years
remember usually by the time you're born
or by
time you're conceived cells duplicate
and we grow
somewhere till around the late teens
early 20s
what happens after that is we need to
maintain
our health and so obviously we don't
pass away at age 20 we just start to hit
our stride
so for growth and development in
particular perhaps with nutrition
endocannabinoids explain a holistic but
very elusive scientific understanding
of what's been called for decades the
brain gut connection
if we go further then and look at
relaxing
relaxing as compared to the eating and
sleeping which is the way
many people think of cannabis today most
people who use cannabis therapeutically
tend to use it before bedtime
and certainly cannabis effects on eating
people think of the munchies
but again try not to think about it in
terms of cannabis
think about this in context of evolution
survival
growth think about the importance now of
relaxing
because it really ensures our ability to
recover
from life's relentless stressors while
this guy might be looking like he's just
sitting back there
chilling and i can't tell you for sure
because i didn't take the picture
if he's uh had any cannabis he's doing
what the body
naturally does through its body's own
cannabinoids
and that's relaxing without the ability
to relax we wouldn't be able to calm
down
and to basically control how the
different stressors of life
affect us so that's the importance of
relaxing
one of the more fascinating though
components of how cannabinoids work
is they actually work at parts of our
brain contributing to
our ability to forget
and those parts of the brain are
actually located in a similar region to
where that eraser is
but it's not simply an inconvenience
being able to forget it's an ability
and it's actually essential for survival
so when i give talks about how important
it is to be
able to forget i want to tell you that
naturally
it doesn't happen through cannabis
although
many people who use cannabis in
particular you would think of patients
perhaps
trying to keep a an unpleasant memory
from recurring
use cannabis to in a sense help to
forget
but that's not the natural way the
body's designed
and the receptors that are found in
parts of the brain
in particular the hippocampus and the
amygdala which deal with emotions and
memories
are essential to the way a healthy human
being
forgets certain things now i'd like to
go a little deeper into this now for a
moment because
this field can be fascinating on many
respects
the ability to forget is
determined through cannabinoids and if
we're going to give an example of how
important
it is to forget why do we think about
those stressors that are not related to
cannabis but
perhaps encountered by an ancient uh
tribe of nomadic human beings long
before
cannabis was known or present to where
it's being used
let's pretend if we were all that
nomadic tribe and we were
foraging for survival to find a squirrel
or a fish or something just to survive
that day and out of nowhere comes a
terrifying beast chases us
uh we scamper up a tree we're hungry
maybe we're
we're bleeding our muscles are tight our
hearts are pounding
if when nightfall comes we can't recover
by relaxing falling to sleep and perhaps
most importantly
forgetting the sheer terror of that
moment
we may not be able the following morning
perhaps to get out of that tree we've
hidden in
to escape and once that animal comes
back and sees us trapped up there
our survival is not likely so the
ability to forget
incredibly stressful moments is
hardwired
into us through cannabinoids our bodies
own cannabinoids that's really
something that could go to the essence
of post-traumatic stress disorders
for an understanding perhaps again of
why
people who are afflicted with that may
find
cannabis to be helpful therapeutically
so that's only talking about it in terms
of its effects on on the stresses
of of pain but
we also incur certain experiences in
life
that are actually pleasurable and it's
not necessarily helpful
to remember the extremes of pleasure
either i have a slide coming up a few
slides from now that may
present where that intersection is and
i'll segue into that in just a moment
but the way that these receptors work
naturally in us
was revealed in a very interesting way
for forgetting and memory
in a case report that presented last
year
and it involved the lady with modern
genetics we now can identify
certain genetic variants that sometimes
are very helpful in revealing
how the body's own system works and in
this case
a lady in scotland reported
that as an adult she went through a life
of really not feeling that painful
things
dentist work even the thing that called
this to the attention which was a
painful
orthopedic surgery procedure on her
wrist
she didn't need the normal medicines or
perceive
pain as an uncomfortable experience the
way
really virtually everybody else does
and she also tested in an interesting
way in that
certain psychological tests that are
there to de
designed to assess anxiety
she scored virtually a zero on those
tests which is unheard of
so here you have a case report of an
individual
who really doesn't feel pain or anxiety
that very often they go hand in hand
like other human beings
and when they looked at her genetics
they found that she's
missing something that breaks down
anandamite
fatty acid amide hydrolase is the enzyme
that we all have
that breaks down our body's own
endogenous
cannabinoid called anandamide and so she
presumably has a very high circulating
level of that particular chemical in her
that presents her with having these
particular
effects seen out of proportion with
things that should necessarily be
healthy because she's not a necessary
and healthy person at all
if she touches something she she likely
has experiences with pain
where she doesn't respond and can worsen
an injury
or anxiety from things that should evoke
a certain amount of anxiety
isn't felt by her but equally
interesting
is in context with what we were just
speaking about with
being able to remember things the
ability to forget
she actually has significant problems
with memory and memory impairment so
here you have a genetic exception
that gives validity to the way we
understand at least the teaching model
that i'm presenting here for the
importance of being able to forget
so in terms of not simply pleasure
but i mentioned before about pain
pain is actually also something that we
mentioned a moment ago is important to
forget
but what about pleasure and what about
if we were to
say a moment that same analogy to an
ancient or prehistoric
tribe where people derived
pleasure not by finding drugs to abuse
or things like that
but the way human beings still derive
pleasure which could be through sex
um the ability for a group as a nomadic
tribe
to be able to forget not simply painful
and stressful things but the ability
perhaps to forget the extremes of
pleasure
are also hardwired in us and in fact
when you think about not being able to
forget extremes of pleasure
in contrast to a patient who could not
forget extremes of pain like ptsd and
are constantly trying to avoid it
to a non-helpful level or
non-therapeutic point
those people that might not be able to
forget the extremes of pleasure
and are constantly seeking it have their
own issues and potentially that may be
one of the
causations of dependency and and
different types
of of addictions so
the interesting point here is i've had
some fascinating discussions including
with professor michoulem
about hundreds of chemicals that exist
in our brains that resemble
some of these endogenous cannabinoids
that we have in us
and their chemical structures are
fascinating to think how they might be
interacting
maybe in this same area of the brain
where these forgetful
not necessarily forgetful but abilities
to forget
are harnessed and isn't it interesting
that
at least as far as what mushulum says he
doesn't think that god just put those
hundreds of chemicals there for the fun
of it
so what we might be looking at at least
theoretically but it's a fascinating
subject
is that if they are there and they're
involved in our abilities to deal with
these
stressors of life whether pleasure or
pain
and what we choose to forget the
difference is that you
as an individual might have versus
myself or anybody else you meet
with life's experiences in terms of what
we seek
or reject pleasure or pain
are really the principal components of
our personality
and we know very little about the
biochemical basis for personality
and i'm growing more and more convinced
that it may lie within the science of
endocannabinoids
so as we move on then to the last of the
five things
that de marzo mentioned we now are
shifting to cb2
receptors the ones that i said in many
respects we know less about but may be
critically important
for understanding how diseases we
encounter become chronic
and in fact that's what happens with
advancing
age we rely on those cp2 receptors
to respond and mitigate the progression
of disease
the reason that's important is when we
pass
on our death certificate there's usually
one disease that's listed as our cause
of death
but along with it we generally die with
many
diseases that are held in a chronic
state
that we die with but not directly from
the reason we can die with them is
because we have
a healthy working functional cannabinoid
system that are working through
cb2 receptors here that should pretty
much
differentiate between the other
components of the importance of
eating and sleeping and relaxing and
forgetting cb1 functions generally is
the way i like to think of that
versus cb2 receptors there to protect us
so this is a good slide because here it
shows
cb2 receptors in an arteriole
and it mentions some of the things that
cb2 receptors do
for showing how blood can flow cellular
proliferation
the endothelial cell activation these
cb receptors are found throughout the
body
with one notable exception
cb receptors are not found in the
portion of the brain stem
called the medulla and pons that's
dedicated to respiration
it's the area of the brain which allows
you to have the stimulation to breathe
so unlike endorphin receptors which
respond to
narcotics which is the source for how
come you'll have these
accidental opioid overdose deaths
where with enough opioids people's brain
stem
is affected and they are not able to
respond by breathing
that when when one can't breathe and
this is an anesthesiologist speaking
nothing else matters you don't see
respiratory depression producing a fatal
outcome
purely from cannabinoids or cannabis
even with doses exceeding tens of
thousands of
times normal therapeutic doses and that
brings a different element of safety
profile
for that lethal outcome now that's not
to say
that it doesn't cause irresponsible
action
or falling asleep while at the wheel
people of course have died
but it's not from the mechanism of
overdosing that we see
especially with opioids and other drugs
that affect the respiratory drive
sections
of the brain nevertheless cb2 receptors
exist and even ancient cultures would
have had a knowledge of this
in a sense and that's what this slide is
meant to show
this is what's called a pet scan
and if you look very closely it's not
just the areas that are red and orange
colored
but i'd like you to look at all the
colored areas not the dark blue
background or black
but you'll see by one of the hands
there's a little red spot not the
largest on the screen but where the hand
would be
that's an intravenous site where a
particular chemical that's
meant to engage cp2 receptors
had an iv site and the cb this
preparation
was injected and two hours later
this pet scan finds out where did that
chemical
actually engage cb2 receptors
and you'll see it's not in the brain
it's not so much in the heart and the
lungs
as the driving force of what's up in the
chest
it's essentially located in the gut and
that's where the immune system is
so this is a parallel system to the
immune system which we know
is essential to our well-being the
orange colors
are more representative also of the
blood flow still bringing this there
so the area of the liver which is the
largest red section even the kidneys
and certain orange areas is not the
teaching moment here
it's that life forces for
endocannabinoids
as well as the immune system tend to be
things that are in
the gut even ancient
chinese understood this because if you
look at
acupuncture and how whatever is
understood about acupuncture
which was not understood hundreds of
years ago
it involves a concept of wellness called
chi
it's spelled q i but pronounced chi and
we know that she represents
flow in and out of different parts of
the body
and even though this is not the way we
teach
medicine in western cultures this is
eastern medicine's philosophy that the
flow
of energy through the body is what
sustains life
most of the flow in qi goes through the
abdomen
through these same places of the gut
even though back then
an ancient healer would have no concept
of cb2 receptors or having intravenous
and pet scans
this in essence then is the parallel to
the immune system
which we know is responsible for
immunity
and life so what i've just described
is really western medicine's new science
future meeting eastern medicine's
traditional past as far as how we
understand
what i inferred before we call
integrative medicine
and so if there ever was a smoking gun
in my opinion that brings eastern and
medicine
eastern and western medicine's
understanding of health together
it quite possibly could be that pet scan
on the left
so let's get right into the last of the
objectives and
talk for a moment about legislation
promoting better patient outcome
currently there are 33 states
and dc that have medical cannabis
laws and 11 having legal recreational
use of marijuana in certain states
i'm from florida and florida now has
addressed their concerns with these
accidental opioid deaths
because it's actually mandated here that
non-opioid alternatives
must be discussed with patients before
initiating an opioid
treatment regimen this is an important
understanding
and as a physician i would hope
that physicians have the responsible
ability
especially in states where it's legal
but eventually federally
to have that extra arrow in their quiver
that may be cannabinoid medicines to use
therapeutically
in particular because the evidence-based
data currently as i showed you on the
previous slide
supports that there is substantial
evidence-based data
today to support the use of cannabis
for chronic pain and that is something
we could learn a lot about
and yet the physicians who are getting
into this field now
undergo uh extra scrutiny
and it's likely because of it still
being federally illegal
and it's not simply from from government
health officials
or or only um federal agencies
but our own colleagues might give extra
skepticism
to a physician who sees someone for the
practice
of cannabinoid medicine and
this presents a conflict because
physicians in states where it's legal
are doing it perhaps seeing patients in
that state because they have a license
to practice medicine
in that state but they have a second
license
and that's their dea license which is a
federal standard
and not that many physicians in 2020
have yet embraced seeing patients for
medical cannabis
out of any risk whatsoever as it may be
regarded
to their federal license their dea
license
which is our ability to prescribe
medicines
that's our tool bag so it's
understandable why
as long as cannabis remains federally
prohibited
that many physicians are are not
prepared to see patients
who are seeking cannabis so where does
it put somebody like this guy
this came out several years ago here in
florida
frankly the lady could have been my mom
and yet
this physician doesn't have the benefit
perhaps of those listening to this talk
or keynote
because immediately there seems to be at
least in past years
a knee-jerk response that is not
educated in 2020
of offering narcotics in this case
oxycontin
uh i would hope that physicians are not
regarded this way because this physician
looks
bored and uneducated and this is not the
current practice of medicine
so in an effort to try to look at the
benefits of natural
medicines and the importance of doing
the right
thing all physicians take an oath
and it used to be the hippocratic oath
perhaps the oath of maimonides which is
one that i took uh when i graduated
school many years ago
but i've been honored to give the oath
of medicine at my institution
to tell physicians right from wrong and
i think there is
what's called a bioethical basis from
which we can proceed on this
because the challenge ethically is to
suggest
should a physician offer compassionate
access to cannabis
for its use of a medicine while it
remains under federal prohibition
and the way we generally look at issues
that are medical legal
are through existing medical legal
ethical platforms and opinions
of which the ama the american medical
association does have a position
that says a physician shall respect the
law and also recognize a responsibility
to seek changes in those requirements
that are contrary to the best interests
of the patient
that applies in certain areas but
unfortunately that mindset has not
particularly been helpful
in dealing with the ethical challenges
surrounding cannabis for just the
reasons we covered a moment ago
and that's that there is a different
federal standard
that in this case physicians are not
likely
to extend their efforts on a federal
level and change laws that way
because of how they get unfairly
scrutinized perhaps by their colleagues
and the importance of that dea license
to their practice
nevertheless a bioethical approach
is a bit different because bioethics
don't simply take
medical legal ethics as a discussion
between
doctors and lawyers bioethics involves
the full community and from that sense i
mean
not only doctors and lawyers but
educators
patients clergy government
everyone contributes to a society's
understanding of a bioethical approach
to solving a problem that has an ethical
basis
you can think of other things right to
life
deserves a bioethical platform even stem
cells
and the development that started stem
cell research
off over a decade ago which originally
was restricted with only
certain cell lines being able to be used
it took a
bioethical rationale and process through
reasoning
that now has stem cell technology
available
it's saving hundreds thousands of lives
through a technology that had to go
through that same bioethical process
so with respect to cannabis and
bioethics
sometimes it helps to come up with not
necessarily a
compromise between medical and legal
but a platform from which to say do the
right thing
and so i wanted to put two sentences
together
that present a rationale this first
sentence from the perspective of a
patient
seeking relief and i didn't say pain
here i said an intolerable
symptom of disease or an intolerable
experience
seeking relief from that is a human
natural
instinct and i'm convinced that that
contributes
to many substances therapeutic use
whether
legal or illegal and it's just the way
human beings seem to behave i accept
that
in a patient who comes with that type of
a background
what then becomes of the physician's
approach or the healer's approach
is to go right back to the basics and
say that
the treatment of those intolerable
symptoms is the task
that society bestows upon its healers to
provide humane relief
more than that rationale i'm not sure is
needed
to progress with the whole disposition
that has had
this type of an approach sort of stymied
over the last
50 years which is how many years the
current
designation of cannabis as a schedule
one prohibited substance
has been there even though its knowledge
base for the last 25
has had the benefit of the supporting
science to understand
how and why it works why is this
discussion particularly important now
because when we look at the interest of
public health
and right now our public health concerns
are
dedicated and focused on coronavirus
nevertheless when we look over the last
15 years
at the leading causes of preventable
death of which
coronavirus has just been around for
past 15 weeks
drug abuse all the way to the right
which was back then
was relatively low down 9 to 10 in terms
of the causes of preventable death
and smoking have actually advanced in
different directions
over the last 15 years because of those
changes in education
and information we have now about both
smoking and drug abuse
the differences of what trends now over
the last 15 years
is we see a public health victory
tobacco smoking in the united states is
nowhere near as common as it was years
ago
and yet it is still by far the leading
cause of preventable death globally
drug abuse on the other hand in the last
15 years
has absolutely had an impact on society
through lethal opioid overdoses that
over these past 15 years
has now passed both motor vehicle
collisions and firearm deaths
and with all the attention that we've
paid to reducing motor vehicle
collisions
and firearm deaths it's quite remarkable
that we haven't really controlled drug
abuse deaths
which using by using all of those tools
we may have available
in that arrow quiver analogy i gave a
little while ago
so furthering then in terms of public
health
and what a responsible program's
state medical program would include for
responsible legislation
i like to think of this in terms of what
things could be in responsible
legislation that
impact a given patient's outcome for the
better
and for those of you who may or may not
be able to read on your phone or laptop
these seven points i'm just going to
read them one at a time
by telling you that there are states now
that are considering
these seven potential things to add to
their state's legislation
that ultimately would be regarded as a
federal necessity once cannabis comes
out of federal prohibition
and the first is developing a
responsible
initial standard of care from which
physicians entering the space
can practice medicine by so
practitioner oversight by boards of
medicine
have to have an initial standard of care
rather than having a standard of care
developed from
a lowest common accepted standard
it needs to be regarded as having what
would be the next higher standard
that physicians can provide in this
understanding
that it's an evolving field second would
be
continuous quality improvement now what
do i mean by that
continuous quality improvement metrics
are used in
everything in healthcare currently
hospitals
nursing homes pharmacies everything in
health care goes through an
accreditation
process whereby when there is an
unfavorable
outcome that information is shared
proactively throughout healthcare so
that we
try to make it so that we redesign
things so as not to repeat
that unfavorable patient outcome
and to a certain extent legislators that
ignore the importance of an
accreditation program that approaches
health care this way through continuous
quality improvement
could be hard-pressed to explain why
without this they were allowing bad
outcomes to recur
we don't hear much about too many bad
outcomes yet but as data becomes tracked
i'm certain we'll be hearing about more
the third item here is to initially
constrain conditions
by lending the evidence-based data of
these conclusive high-quality
findings that are conclusive or
substantial
for what it actually works for and we
covered those before
now that doesn't dismiss anecdotal
reports which become the basis
for the hypotheses of future research
but there is a difference with that
evidence-based data versus
anecdotal reports and to recognize
though to initially responsibly and
judiciously
start to release approve things rather
than having
a virtual everything list that fits for
a qualifying condition
i believe is not only a more responsible
way to
to allow this to progress but one in
which the federal government would
embrace rather than allowing disease
states which may not yet have the
benefit of that evidence-based data
then finally on item four
this requires funded research
and in particular with the way cannabis
is understood today
outcomes in children is particularly
important because this
alludes to the importance of what are
called long-term or longitudinal studies
which we have very very few of so it's
not simply for treating a child with
epilepsy right now
but to look at the long-term effects of
when people use cannabis
what are the differences as they mature
and develop
those skills that allow them to deal
with problem
solving that has previously been
connected in
perhaps one of the very few longitudinal
studies that was not perfect
but inferred and concluded that there
could be a drop of intelligence that
would be a great concern
to those children that started at a
young age using cannabis
and continued using it in high doses
consistently for the next
20 years we need these 20 year and more
studies of following one individual to
really determine
the consequences of outcome because we
know very little about
two things concerning modern cannabis
one
is the effective dosing other than
making a general statement
that the current evidence-based data
suggests
that we grossly overdose and that most
findings suggest
that minimal doses are most effective
with the possible exception as evidence
builds for ptsd
and the second thing we know very very
little about are the long-term effects
on what's what called down regulating
when we
change the system's normal complement of
receptors by exposing them to cannabis
and cannabinoids on a chronic basis
what we do know that's encouraging is
that this particular receptor system
tends to be very plastic in its nature
which means
that it has a very high ability to
recover its full complement of receptors
because a federal study in nida the
national institute of drug abuse
looked at people who were chronic heavy
users
that were sequestered and not given
any cannabis products in a controlled
setting and after only about four weeks
they had a near total return of all
their bodies full complement of these
receptors
that's helpful information to determine
how these receptors may be
affected from long-term use then of
course
if you look at different states the
fifth item here about the full and
accurate
labeling of cannabis products is
absolutely needed to facilitate
meaningful data accession
both for the benefit of researchers as
well as the physician and patient
involved
at that time so you got to know what
you're taking and how often to take it
those particular regulations though
that should have the relatively few
experts
available to modify a given state's
qualifying conditions as the new data
allows is important for keeping up with
that new data
so that you don't have to wait
necessarily for a legislative
body to come to political terms when in
fact health care experts
might be able to add or remove certain
conditions from a given state's
qualifying conditions
and then finally resourcing highly
qualified
guidance in the dispensing and the
thoughtful data processing
of this particular medicine is right now
at a critical state
because the person behind the counter
should
could and in many situations will in the
future
be forced to be a trained individual
that's not to say at this moment
trained pharmacists that are degreed are
are ready to fill this void
but a similar training or oversight
uh should advance in that direction for
expertise
especially that that's what pharmacist
as perhaps
an underutilized and under appreciated
resource in this space
should be better appreciated so finally
then in conclusion
there is a take-home message and the
take-home message is where we are at
politically science-wise legislatively
and that take home message really is
that at this moment in time
cannabis whether used recreationally in
the past present or future
is a temptation for many and it's an
indulgence but it
offers certain choices and those of you
familiar with the genie parable where
you get
two wishes and that genie
gives you that third witch which can be
the gotcha one
we right now are in a position to be
very careful with what we wish for and
how we plan on we'd like to have it
available or regulated
because the message here from the talk
in this keynote is that science and
reason
really do matter so for more information
on this as as uh
you may need i can be reached through
nurturing nature group
that's the uh consultancy that i run
and i'd be happy to hear from you and
hopefully we'll be able to link that way
for future information
thanks for your time